what's your name darling agents take the
bed Network for or just criminals like a
like a stick-up man they're in
everything
I'm Mike cymbal from FX guide.com for
white well the Marvel Universe is
expanding yet again into a magical
almost horror genre with the TV show
agent Carter
this season Peggy has moved to LA which
required the normal range of period
location work and green-screen but she's
also been battling against the effects
of the sinister and transformative
substance zero matter zero matter takes
on various forms depending on who it
comes in contact with it sometimes
freezes people and need some Houdini
rigid body shadow effects or in the case
of Jason Wilkes
the character was dimensionally shifted
and this required the effects team to
invent a type of visual developer or
fixer
courtesy of Howard Stark the very nature
of the material itself is that it's
super black which produces a huge range
of visual effects problems most commonly
from the zero matter manifested itself
as sort of a cross between liquid
spiders and a sample of magnetic
ferrofluid assembly which sheena Duggal
the visual effects supervisor took on
set with a magnet to show the cast for
inspiration she not also consulted with
dr. Clifford Johnson a professor of
physics and astronomy at USC it is this
theoretical physicist who provided the
thomas fermi equations that you see on
the blackboards of the show it's also
his pencil sketches and advice on
quantum mechanical theory that were the
basis for the various containment
devices that Wilkes uses such as this
plasma tank which is phasing the
magnetic field in different directions
and is actually inspired by real-world
containment devices and speaking of
building visual effects on the basis of
real-world physicist theories when we
see the film footage from the isodyne
atomic tests of 1946 at the heart of the
explosion is what seems to be a black
hole and the work of science adviser Kip
Thorne this is perhaps not surprising as
double- did the visual effects for agent
Carter and they also wrote a special ray
tracer that actually bends light rays
allowing for the classic accretion disk
shape of a black hole but double- also
had an enormous amount of face tracking
to do this season thanks to the way the
zero matter affected Whitney Frost the
zero matter also required over 20
members of
the cars to be modeled with some 60
photos of each fed into a photogrammetry
piece of software to be used as digital
doubles or as stand in geometry face
tracking can be really complex but
double- has a new optical flow tool
magic warper based on vector motion
tracking or 2d pixel flow and it proved
invaluable for transforming actress
whenever it the transformative an almost
magical zero matter is what marble fans
will recognize as dark force from
marvel's agents of shield and be really
interesting to see if this plays in any
other Marvel properties coming up so
don't forget to subscribe for more
behind the scenes action
I'm Mike Seymour for wide I start you
should be in pictures pack to be the
cowboy don't think the audience is ready
yet but they're ready for a movie based
on a comic book so I was like a direct
phylidia